hey guys welcome back to the games with
stage at e3 2015 we're here in the
lovely Los Angeles Convention Center I
am joined by Tanya who is an executive
producer at Epic Games on your fortnight
which is not a game about being in two
weeks it's up making a forward surviving
the night huh
riot what sort of yes-yes-yes long of a
short of it uh so you guys announced
this game a few years ago yep and it
kind of went quiet
yeah um but it's a really exciting
project I my oversight to dig more into
it yeah um so if you can give us the
basic premise yeah so the basic premise
a fortnight is basically we wanted you
and your friends to answer the question
if you could save the world
how would you rebuild it like this isn't
like about scrounging for beans and
hitting like rabbits in the head with
rocks sir this isn't survival right this
is like long after the apocalypse you
and your friends you know you need to do
to save the world how would you do it
and how would you rebuild it and that's
like kind of the core of fortnight so to
do that you're actually going into the
game you're going into the world you're
exploring it you're finding new things
crafting things building your fort and
closing these gates which allow you to
stop the storms from coming and that's
like how the enemies and the creatures
are coming into the world so I mean if
we okay in the kind of end of the world
scenario yeah where's everybody else
well everyone else are husks oh yeah
they're create their own they're gone
exactly they're creatures so it's just
you you and your friends and there's you
know X number of thousands of you in the
world and you're all working together to
push back the storms and save the world
so I mean from what I've seen of the
game it looks like the game plays in
kind of three stages uh-huh so
scavenging and then building the fort
and then the night time comes
yeah the Nightman cometh yeah so let's
talk a little bit about yeah Gavin Jing
because yeah it looks like we can see
some game right here um it looks like
there's actually a lot of humor in it as
well I don't know when Sean McInnis of X
Games squad went to see the game he said
he found like bacon in the toilet yes I
kind of thing yeah well our worlds are
completely they're completely dynamic
they're completely
scavenger Bowl harvestable right like
everything can be destroyed and
recovered or searched and that's like
one of the things that you do in
fortnight you use all of that stuff so
depending on like the types of
schematics that you've earned to that
point the things you like to build you
use those items in order to build like
your health your guns your weapons your
bullets like in for tonight we have
hundreds of weapons yeah and it's like
it's just up to you and how you like to
play we're giving you all of these tools
that will allow you to kind of like
choose the path that best suits you so
oh wow what are we seeing here
oh so this is one of our special
abilities for our our scavenger class or
Outlander so there are these orbs in the
world that you can get that will allow
you to that was our loot our loot llama
look like a pinata yes it's our loot
pinata so once you find the orb you can
throw it out for you and your friends
and you gather together and you just
beat the crap out of it and you get lots
of awesome stuff so I believe um epic
themselves I'm not sure who said it but
the game's been described as kind of
Minecraft meets left4dead uh-huh and I'm
seeing like Team Fortress in there as
well um kind of I mean these
inspirations that you've drawn or is it
something that just sort of organically
come out no well in the very beginning
it was the inspiration was that we
wanted to make a game that lots of
different like gaming types of people
you know different arc types could play
together and I you know I always talked
about how when I you know would play a
shooter or I play an RPG my two favorite
types I have my friends they're like oh
I don't play shooting games like I'll
never play shooting game with you I
don't play MMO RPGs I'll never play that
with you and and we said well let's make
a game where you can have those people
play together like there's no reason
right and we really love this idea of
having this world where you get to make
all the choices and you get to make the
rules and you get to decide how you want
to go about it yeah and if you're
someone who likes I love to play support
classes like usually when I play games
and so being able to place a constructor
and plan out how we're going to build
the fort and where the defenses are
going to be and what are the upgrades
gonna be and I'm like telling people
okay guys we need more stone like bring
me
stone the Outlanders go out they bring
me stone right that is to me that's like
what makes fortnight really special
that's where you get all of those
influences you see the influences from
all these other games it's because it's
very it was very purposeful we said like
no we want four shooter fans there's our
commando class that's for you right for
our support class our support fans we've
got the Outlander and our constructor
and then for like your melee close up
combat speed guys you got the ninja I
love how it's just kind of everyone
makes sense and then there's a really
cool ninja just yeah tagging along well
you always have to have like a really
cool like for the long game of fortnight
so we're building fortnight as this game
that had hundreds of hours yeah and then
you know the thing that we have right
now in our in our alpha is just one of
the different types of game modes that
you can do where you're closing the gate
but in the in the long game it's like
we're going to have lots of classes lots
of environments different resource types
we've already got our PvP mode is in
prototype right now and it's crazy
because like if you can imagine playing
you know a third-person shooter where
now you get to build the level and tear
down the level and scavenge for stuff
and it's like the strategy that gets
employed there's it's crazy so how I
would kind of like the longer game work
because obviously it's people playing
online if I was playing with like a
specific group of friends yes and we all
had to go you know get dinner or
something yeah how would we kind of just
pause it I won't drop out yeah one
person no so everyone has everyone has
their own persistent home base yeah and
your home base it's like all based on
your progression the types of things you
like to do the classes you like to play
as the heroes that you think are cool
and for each individual it's going to be
different right it's based on your
perspective but when you get together
you can say like okay what do you need
what do you want to do do you want to do
this type of mission or that type of
mission oh I need to get this kind of
resource like let's go and let's go into
this part of the world and get this
stuff or like oh my god there's a new
update like let's go over here and do
this instead yeah so you guys can kind
of like login check out see what you
want to do and and it's all persistent
to your own
yeah that's awesome so let's talk a
little bit about because the game is
free yes um and although the words you
know free-to-play you fail people with
fear yeah and games like Team Fortress
they it's proven that it it works him
also house you as your model gonna work
so we we've taken the attitude from the
very beginning we want to make it free
to play and is a big part of the
development strategy because you when
you talk about getting lots of people of
different playstyles together like you
want there's no barrier event yeah
exactly
written yeah you want my people to give
it a chance like people will say well I
don't play shooting games it's like it's
free just give it a try and see and
you'll see that there's a way that you
can play the game but for us we really
took inspiration from games like tf2 and
dota and League and and we're looking at
man if we make a game that's just really
fun that people really want to spend
money in because they love it yeah
that's it it'll build it and they will
come as Field of Dreams that's it that's
so we have right now we have a really
kind of a simplistic model there just we
have a card pack system yep right and if
you want to buy them you can buy them
and if you don't you know you don't have
to and we're going to be iterating on
our monetization like we're going to
figure it out and the best way but this
is a big you know this is the first time
we've done a game like this yeah so
we're very much like looking at feedback
and taking in you know community
response and we'll see how it goes so
you guys are an alpha or no yes
how can play is get access to that you
can go to a fortnight calm and you can
just sign up right there on fortnight
calm and if you're if you want to see
any updates from us we've got at
fortnight game on Twitter or of course
you can like us on Facebook but if you
sign up then you may very well be
invited in to a now hold in tune it yeah
but we have our closed beta uh-huh
starting this fall on both Mac and PC
wonderful yeah Tonya thank you so much
joining me guys make sure you stay tuned
here at the GameSpot stage we're going
nowhere it's easy 2015 there are
hundreds of awesome games and we've got
a ton of them on our stage tada
you